welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar streamlining the
biologics development process from
transient to stable production in the XP
Cho system it is presented by John zmuda
PhD director of cell biology in the life
sciences solutions group at Thermo
Fisher Scientific my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. zmuda I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you Judy for the introduction as
Judy mentioned my name is jonathan zuo
i'm a director of cell biology at Thermo
Fisher Scientific Base in Frederick
Maryland in the u.s. today I will be
talking about streamlining the biologics
development process going from transient
protein expression to stable production
using the X P Chow expression system so
the first question is why cho cells for
transient expression and I think most of
us on the on the call today will realize
that Cho is still the preeminent cell
line for bio production
of biologics and various therapeutic
entities and to date still 70% or
greater of biologics are manufactured in
show cells and it appears as though that
trend will certainly stay similar for
the next years or decades to come so
accurate post translational
modifications make Cho derived proteins
relevant for critical studies including
biological activity pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics as well as the
instances where some protein simply
won't Express well in heck to 9-3 cells
another typical cell line utilized for
transient protein expression and ideally
what we would like to see out of the
transient show drive material is a
predictive potential for using the
results that we see in the transient and
derived material sites into the stable
show production setting so overall what
we would like to see and be able to
enable is a seamless transition from
discovery to clinic to commercial
manufacturing such that we D risk the
biologics development process by
starting our work in show and staying in
show throughout the entire commercial
development process so in the past
historically what were the challenges
with transient show and as we see on the
slide here in the right you've seen the
X be 293 expression system based on HEC
293 cells researchers are able to get
typically in the hundreds to Gram
hundreds of milligrams per liter to a
gram per liter range expression for
their antibodies however the older chobe
systems such as freestyle cho typically
had about a 5 a 50 to 100 fold lower
expression rate often in the 10 to 20
milligram per liter range which really
wasn't enough protein for researchers to
do the types of studies that they needed
to do so this led to a very high cost in
terms of both time and dollars per
milligram of protein when generated in
the transient cho cells of the time
however the alternatives including
making stable cell lines in cho
significantly length and time lines and
cost associated with that protein
production so for met the era's
researcher
were more or less required to make the
protein that they needed in the two nine
three cells where they could get higher
titers versus the very small amounts of
proteins coming out of the Cho transient
systems so how were we able to attain
higher titers in the transient protein
expression and really very similar to xB
two nine three as I showed in the last
slide that has been enabled by utilizing
a systems-based approach whereby he
sells the media the transcription
reagents the vector the feeds and
expression techniques are all optimized
to work together and synergistically
such that the biggest protein titers
available from transient protein
expression can be attained and in the
case of the XP echo system that system
comprises the xB gos high expressing
cell line the or next we show expression
media the active effect image
high-efficiency transfection reagent the
xB geo feed an enhancer to enable and to
boost the highest expression levels out
of the cells as well as a high
expressing pcdna 3.4 vector and it's
only when all of these components are
put together and utilized that we can
get these very big synergistic boosts in
transient protein expression such that
we can get very high titers out of cho
cells and in many instances even higher
than in the traditional at 293 based
transient systems so all of this starts
foundationally with our xB gos cells and
the a troops of the key attributes that
this cell line is that these these cells
the xB chögyam Joe s cells are derived
from our GMP Cho s cell line they're
adapted for high-density culture so
these cells will reach greater than 20
million cells per mil and standard shape
class cultures they double very rapidly
so about a 17 date in our doubling time
they have a high transfection efficiency
and they're stable for growth and
expression profiles for at least 20
passages these cells as I'll show later
generate proteins that have show like
like oscillation profiles and post
translational modifications
and the protein coming out of these
cells is high-quality and biologically
active and to date we do also have a GMP
X bicho cell banks that are available
for biologics manufacturing in the GMP
settings so as we look at some of the
expression levels here we show
expression in the X P Cho transient
expression system for a panel of five
biosimilar human monoclonal or humanized
monoclonal antibodies and here we see
across these five monoclonal antibodies
expression levels in the one to two plus
gram per liter range and these transient
expression levels really rival awesome
cho production and certainly those the
stable show has has come a long way and
the titers have been significantly
improved over the years but these are
within this gram per liter range that
will certainly allow researchers to
generate the material that they need for
their preclinical studies in using cho
derived protein so this high low the
high level of protein expression allows
for protein discovery in very small
scales so previously relatively larger
scales had to be utilized to get the
protein that was required out of cho
cells however with these very high gram
per liter and and higher levels of
protein expression research our
researchers are enabled to go into
ninety-six deep well plates for one to
two ml expression runs i throughput
screening type formats the 24 deep well
plates that allows up to about 300 mils
of expression as well as the 50 ml mini
bioreactors that use on the right-hand
side of the slide that allows up to
about 25 milliliters of expression so
these high titers have enabled scale
down of the system such that discovery
can begin very early on in the transient
co system scaled up into the 25 ml mini
bio reactors as well as then scaled all
the way
two three or five liter shake glass at
which time typically the high expression
levels of the system will allow you for
to achieve the titers that you need for
your or your research so following on in
terms of high-throughput screening we
have automated the XP Cho system as well
to run on the amber 15 system such that
we can identify conditions that are
optimal for high-throughput screening
using the XP Cho system and here the
conditions are quite similar to what we
utilize for high throughput in the
manual setting with only slight
differences in terms of how the complex
ation reaction is generated such that
the complexes remain stable and allow
for the highest transfection efficiency
and protein titers during the automated
expression run on the amber 15 system
the material and proteins that are
generated in the XP Cho system also have
the potential to be modulated in terms
of their post translational
modifications and two examples here one
done in our lab shown on the left hand
side where we've modulated the
glycosylation patterns of the XP Cho
derived proteins starting from the red
bar which is what the xB Cho system
delivers in its in it's holistic format
and then when we have added in feeds of
different like hand modulations you can
see that we go from about a 90% g0f
glencoe form down to about 70% g0f by
modulating the feed profile in the xB
Cho system such that we've changed by
about 20% the level of g0f in the blue
bar you'll actually see the
corresponding like oscillation patterns
of the X b-29 3 system so we've actually
been able to drive down that at g0f and
you can see the the concordant increase
in the g1 F and G 1 F 2 as well as the G
to F glyco forms where as we modulate
them in the xB Cho system similar to how
this
stable Choa derived materials can be
modulated in the bioreactor setting in
the upper right you'll see the the
header for a recently published paper
discussing optimizing the end like
cancelation for therapeutic
glycoproteins in the XP co system so
very similar to how like Oh forms and
post translational modifications can be
optimized in a stable Cho setting if
attained similar optimizations and
changes to the post translational
modifications of proteins in the
transient x bicho setting in terms of
protein quality what you see on the left
hand side is a non reduced gel for
purified human IgG samples and on lanes
three four and six you'll see xB Cho
derived material transiently dried
material from the three different xB Cho
protocols the standard high titer and
max titer protocols and at the bottom
you'll see the corresponding a grams per
liter of titer for those various samples
in Lane seven you'll see the same
protein expressed in a stable Cho s
setting and in Lane eight expressed in
xB to 93 transient to 93 based system so
both for the non reduced on the left and
the reduced samples on the right we see
very similar banding patterns post
protein a purification for the protein
regardless of whether it was generated
in the transient or stable Cho or XP to
93 setting as well as regardless of the
titer attained in the crude supernatant
if we look at size exclusion
chromatography following protein a
purification for the xB Cho system on
the top you'll see our standard tighter
or XP Cho transient expression run
that's performed at 37 c and you'll see
a chromatograms for day 5 and day 8
harvest times and in both instances we
have 94 to 95 percent monomer in the
middle chromatogram you'll see utilizing
the XP cho high
tighter expression run where we shift
the temperature - 32 C and here we've
harvested on day 5 and day 11 again
between about 94 95 percent monomer and
lastly on the bottom where we've
utilized the max titer expression run
where we utilize two feeds and a 32 C
tempt and harvest all the way out at day
14 very similar to a stable show
expression run again we're still in that
95 percent monomer 2 criteria so we're
getting very good monomeric protein
regardless of the temperature of
expression and the day of harvest and
the XP geo transients lastly when
looking at like oscillation patterns we
can see in the top in the top
chromatogram we see the XP cho transient
yko pattern we see about 82% g0f with
less of the G on F and G to F so
primarily a g 0f + XP cho transient very
similar to stable Cho s the middle lane
about 87 percent 0f but both of these
significantly different than XP to 93
where we see more of the G 1 F and G to
F glyco forms compared to either of the
Cho systems
so both transient XP Cho and stable Cho
s derived to Panaji t have very similar
Boyko patterns compared to xB to 93 that
are quite different so in the next part
of my presentation I would like to
introduce some new reagents that allow
for further streamlining the transient
to GMP stable protein production using
our newly released XP Cho stable
production medium so this X bgo stable
production medium as you see on the
right and our XP gos GMP cell bank cells
are additions to the XP cho transient
expression system such that now we
enable this team through the GMP
manufacturing large-scale manufacturing
of the XP show derives proteins the XP
chose stable production media is
available both in the liquid and in an
ADT or advanced granulation technology
dry format that tremendously helps to
streamline scale scale up production so
some of the key benefits of the AGT dry
format is that the AGT upon
reconstitution auto pH is itself so it's
a simple addition of water there's a
very fast dissolution and mixing time
there's dust free addition to the tank
and minimal filtration pressure build-up
during the during the reconstitution so
all of this allows for the easy scale-up
of stable XP choked production runs
utilizing the a GT formatted XP chose
stable expression medium so I'll now
move into a case study on developing a
high producing X Beach OS stable clone
and what we show here is the very
typical stable cell line development
workflow going from following your ex
beach OS GMP cell bank to allowing those
cells to grow for a number of passages
two to four passages and then these
cells are transfected so these cells are
grown in the XP Cho expression media for
the transient protein expression they're
transfected using the expo fective eacho
transfection reagent and then they go
through a very typical two step
selection process in this case an
antibiotic selection process the cells
are then put through limited dilution
cloning and the resultant clones are
scaled up and primary and secondary
screen followed by a re testing in a fed
batch shake flask environment and
leading into a clonal stability study so
what we show here is very typical
selection curves for XP Cho single cell
clones on the left-hand side you see the
pool viability following the first
selection and the
the recovery followed by the second
selection to generate their final stable
clothes
so from these stabili transfected clones
in our primary screen we generated 95
clones following stability assessment 35
of them showed good stability over
multiple passages following the
secondary screen for protein expression
we identified eight clones the tertiary
screen generated our top three and
finally we picked our final clone based
on this screening scenario so here we
were enabled to generate we were able to
generate a single xB show clone
producing greater than 3 grams per liter
of a human IgG which is consistent with
the typical titer today of about 3 to 3
and a half grams per liter from stabili
expressing cho cell lines although as I
mentioned previously many systems now
will generate higher titers in the 10
gram per liter but this 3 gram per liter
that we were able to attain was with
very minimal optimization of the system
as we were simply looking for a bottle
protein to demonstrate the ability of
moving from transient xB Cho to stable
XP Cho so the other nice thing about
sticking with the xB Cho expression
media into the stable production media
is that the xB geocell will can be
directly adapted into the sand media
used for cnred the Cho expression media
so this is used for the transient
expression system and in blue the xB
show stable production media and here I
will take a moment to just point out one
difference between these two media's is
that the XP Cho expression media is
useful for transient expression so it
has no components that impact negatively
transient protein expression whereas the
xB Cho stable production media does have
componentry that is more tailored to
stable production
in a large format that will inhibit
transient protein expression so all
transient expression of this of the
proteins and the generation of the
stable cell lines should be performed in
the xB Cho expression media here we show
again in red and blue that either the xB
Cho expression media for transient
expression or the xB chose stable
production media and blue have very
similar growth profiles over multiple
passages and there's a seamless
transition of the cells from the xB Cho
transient expression media into the
stable production media in gray we show
two competitor media where we see lower
growth rates as well as more variability
in the viable cell densities at the time
of harvest for those different media's
so again this direct adaptation from the
transient to the stable media saves time
and effort in that this is a seamless
transition from one to the next
similarly this stable xB Cho s clone was
running an amber 15 fed batch process
and once again in blue and red you see
the xB Cho stable production media here
the blue circles indicate xB chose
stable production media formulated from
the AG t powdered format and in read
from standard liquid manufacturing
process both of these once again you
will see that the x cones and this will
attain my viable cell densities the
course of the expression rum compared to
either of the competitor medias and on
the right hand side you can see once
again that in the amber 15 small-scale
process this clone is is still
expressing in the three to three and a
half gram per liter range for either the
xB Cho a GT or liquid media and
significantly higher than either of the
competitor media we next look to scale
up this X P Cho s clone stable clone
into large-scale stirred tank bio
reactors and here we show data going
into a 50 liter
a thermo scientific high perform a
single-use bioreactor on the left-hand
side we see the viable cell density
traces once again reach attaining that
15 to 20 million cells per mil viable
cell density and on the right hand side
we see the accumulation of the
immunoglobulin being produced over about
17 days once again hitting that three
and a half approximately gram per liter
maximum titer
during this expression run so we've
shown now between shake flasks amber
micro bioreactors and all the way up to
50 liters single-use bioreactors getting
very consistent protein titers out of
this xB Cho s stable clone and similar
to the data that I showed earlier
comparing the transient black
oscillation profiles of XP Cho to stable
Cho s and XP 2 9 3 cells here we're
showing on the left like oscillation
patterns for transient XP Cho derived
human IgG and on the right stable e
expressing XP Cho clones expressing the
same Cuban IgG and very typical of what
we see in these glycosylation profiles
there are there tend to be some minimal
differences between the transient and be
stable and of note calling out here and
the transient we sometimes will see very
long expression runs so here harvested
on day 14 you can sometimes see a slight
uptick in the man 5 at these very long
harvest dates in the transient system as
these transient shake flasks are
building up an accumulating metabolic
waste at that time they don't have this
similar amount of control as the
bioreactors where as you see on the
right with the very controlled
bioreactors the level of man 5 is
extremely low one other typical change
that we see is a bit of an uptick in the
g1 F profile in the stable setting
versus in the transient setting where we
typically see very consistently g0f as
the predominant cueca form but in
general both of these patterns are quite
similar with just some of the
characteristic differences in transient
versus stable that we've witnessed in in
multiple molecules so with that I'd like
to just summarize this this talk today
and really discuss this seamless
solution for transient to stable product
protein production in XP Chow and the XP
Cho system from transient to stable
provides the ability of Rick for
researchers to generate rapid high titer
protein protein expression using a
relevant cho cell background it enables
this seamless flow from transient to
stable Cho generates consistent product
quality attributes between XP Cho
transient and XP Cho stable derived
protein as well as allowing for the
licensing of GMP banked XP gos cell line
such that a researcher working in
transient XP Chow and looking to de-risk
their movement into stable cell line
production I can now work directly
through transient XP Cho into a stable
Cho bio production a GMP setting and
finally the launch of the XP chose
stable production media available
available in both liquid or a GT format
allows for large-scale stable production
in the XP Cho cell background so with
that I'd just like to take a moment to
acknowledge a number of folks on the R&D
team for the XP Cho transient system as
well as for our XP Cho stable production
media and with that I thank you and I
look forward to answering questions
coming from this presentation thank you
very much thank you dr. zmuda for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcasts possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 30th
20-19 as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time bye